well Jenny seems like a special lady how
did you propose uh we proposed I went
took her to Catalina nor Catalina Island
been there there's nothing there there's
nothing there I probably won't work for
the Catalina Tourism Board there's
nothing there oh there's a bunch of
Buffalo they left no they shot a movie
what that's really what happened okay
yeah so I we went out to Catalina and I
had a diamond in my the you know that
little pocket on your jeans oh the
diamond ring yeah and of course this is
the most expensive thing I'd ever had
was in my jeans pocket other than like a
Saab 900s in the 80s so I was real
nervous and almost I've seen I guess I
seemed kind of mad cuz I was just like
walking and like clutching the thing and
like freaking out and like don't lose
the Saab in your pocket you know and so
she thought that I was bringing her to
this garden to break up oh yeah yeah and
she was super surprised people bring
people to beautiful places to break up
my next thought she was like oh this is
great news she started crying she's like
this is great cuz I thought we were
breaking up and I was like if I brought
you to an island to the top of a hill
that's like what dr. evil would do or
[Laughter]
how did how did
Ozzy proposed here oh he asked my
father's permission first yeah and then
he went out and got me a ring but he got
me a wedding ring not an engagement ring
so he bent down he gave me the ring and
it was lovely and then the next week we
had a huge fight I took the ring off ice
really into the bushes
that's a very passionate relation
I see is my husband's bummers is on the
ground I'm looking for the ring on the
bushes 37 years later it worked I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my YouTube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this